so you just got yourself an oculus we
get it reality is a bit much right now
boonies avocado toast clickbait and
trashy tweets when you can step into a
world with a little more of this yeah
that's what we thought
so here's our take on some of the best
VR game experiences you can get for your
oculus rift feel like well-written
science fiction adventures of course you
do
you're smart you play video games and
loan echo you play as a service Android
named Jack aboard a mining station when
a mysterious anomaly crosses your path
with an immersive locomotion system
compelling character interaction and an
intriguing mystery at its core mold echo
is the perfect scratch for your science
fiction edge
by the asteroids
[Music]
live out your slow-mo action fantasies
with superhot VR in this part of the
popular Keanu Reeves like simulator you
can run dodge punch throw and shoot your
way through its crimson Legion of bad
guys without fear of actual death in
this number name but tread carefully one
wrong move and oh you need to get good
holy crap brick you made a Morty clone
Rick to be fair you don't need to have a
very high IQ to enjoy this schwifty
adventure
grab your plum bus and venture into the
realms unknown with Rick and Morty
virtual reality explorer icon occations
from the series take on hostile aliens
summon your own personal musics and do
Rick's laundry Squatch it I'm in I'm
going vegan this is canon marty is not
vegan this is canon introducing the
newest innovation in tabletop strategy
games baked tables that's right in brass
tactics you can command an array of
customizable units to decimate your
friends upon a genuine state of the art
imaginary table complete with over 20
unique maps and an entertaining 6 plus
our story campaign gone are the days of
resting units upon a tangible flat
surface the future has truly arrived
congratulations we've destroyed arrows
Castle can't get enough of lone echo
I've got four words for you
zero gravity robot deathmatch yeah
that's right echo VR utilizes the same
locomotion based zero-gravity controls
of lone echo but with the added thrill
of glorious Robo combat this might break
at least two laws of robot physics but
who cares about laws when you have
shoulder-mounted explosives and laser
guns
so there you have it five games five
reasons to stop debating politics with
your annoying uncle Steve five ways to
forget about those impending deadlines
for a bit but your search for a better
reality shouldn't stop here there's
plenty of fun rift experiences on the
oculus store so for more info on other
great VR titles along with some cool VR
apps head over to GameSpot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]